after watching this movie you will never
want to associate your mother as mama
ever again it's that rare horror movie
that has you emotionally invested as
well as scaring the bejesus out of you
I've never been scared so shitless about
two little kids that I cared so goddamn
much about this film is later it's like
a psychological horror film with
mythical and fantasy aspects to it it
takes a ghost story from a psychological
level the film's foundation is really
about its characters you get to know and
understand every one of them especially
the great actress Jessica Chastain and
the two scary [ __ ] who are
awesome in this film there staring when
they're scary and you care about them
when the director wants you to care
about them as far as the actual mama
goes the visual effects on her a
top-notch and she did scare the [ __ ] out
of me literally the film supernatural
horror builds throughout this film the
movie doesn't try to [ __ ] their
audience they're very up front that the
kids are interacting with a ghost and it
has fun letting the audience know before
the main characters even know this film
definitely has Guillermo del Toro's
horror fantasy stamp on it but the
credit for this above-average scare
flick really goes to co-writer director
Andre muschietti all in all i gotta say
mama got it right
you